Howard cross Howard is works for the
Giants their sideline reporter and
former Giants tight in how you feeling
today Howard what did you see on the
sidelines last night you know I saw a
team that the struggling have to replace
like 30-plus players they're trying to
find a way to pull them all together
but unfortunately the drafts over the
last I guess eight to ten years haven't
been great for the team and they just
don't have the guys I don't have they
don't have them office your wine it's
tough for them they got you know they
overpaying for a few guys here and there
trying to you know patch some holes they
just haven't got it done yet don't take
for a while okay the difference between
effort and execution if if I said is it
about effort with the Giants or is it
more about execution
it's totally execution the guys aren't
you can see guys in the wrong place you
can see you know guys getting beat you
know they're giving the best they can
give but they're gonna beat like this
there's out man in third position
sometimes for the first time ever you
saw Eli complaining about a guy not
running or the right route you never see
him say anything to anyone he's finally
like raised his hands and this point in
like what are you doing yeah the guy
comes as silent even a coach that what
are you doing so it's just again guys
missing assignments not really sure and
they're just you know short week they
had a bad a bad bad guy
we knew the line was bad last year you
bring in Nate's older and they were
still expecting Erik flowers to act like
a professional tackle you know nobody
can be surprised that the line is bad
are you surprised at that it's this bad
I was hoping I think I was hoping a lot
less than Eli's over you know I saw them
tremendously but he is you know God
bless his soul he's 37 he might be still
like it's 57 as many hits as he's taken
that's pretty it's pretty bad guys would
beat him like an three-step drops are
hitting him in the second step of the
three-step drop and running backs are
getting touched in the backfield twice
it just depends on who's the hot down or
Islander like picking and choosing each
other
it's tough for me they're having a hard
time but it's it's really tougher so
we're six games in it's bad how much
worse can it get it's not gonna get
worse they just gotta figure out ways to
to improve a little bit here and there I
didn't expect them to have like this
stellar season I expect from the house
if they want four or five games out have
been impressed you know when you when
you have that much turnover on your team
it's just I know people think that you
can patch you know patch a lot of holes
and they could work but if you don't
have any poor guys it's just very tough
one I think you know if you think about
the Giants draft over the last few years
of the first third first second and
third-round picks from I think 2011 on I
don't think any of those guys are on the
same sake one Barclay feels like there's
a Barry Sanders quality and and I mean
mostly positives with that but it feels
like there's one yard three yards you
know five yards 45 yards then Barry used
to do that I don't know how much that is
sake one Barclays running style or the
offensive line because we can go back to
Barry Sanders that Detroit line wasn't
very good either
do you see similarities between these
two Oh totally you know say Kwan and
Barry you know Barry came in same year I
came in and watching him play with you
know and the team that didn't really
have a tight end to help protect him on
the edges she took kicks in the back
till guys are good afternoon all of a
sudden I got would miss and it's like a
key like a swing and miss what a minute
those 60 yards down the hill take one's
basically doing the same thing and it's
pretty amazing to watch guys are I think
the funny thing is guys are trying to
tackle and super low and he just jumps
over them and keeps running which I'm
like we were always talking never a jump
but he seems to be doing it make you cut
and spin on a dime and change direction
and when we gets out in the open the
feel like it's almost he's gone he's a
lot of fun to watch and and I think that
this is you know validating taking him
number two overall and you know I think
they're they're always going to be
second-guessed depending on how well
darn old plays or Josh Rosen plays or
Josh Allen plays moving forward do you
think Eli's the quarterback next year I
don't know it depends on how high they
draft is in the dress and that's
really in today today I'd like you know
top five picks and when those guys looks
like a franchise guy
they'll take they'll take the
quarterback meal I had like another year
of his contract so that that would be
there the only catch I don't think
they're going to extend them past this
year you know but you know I would think
the question is going to be are there
gonna be like two or three huge
offensive linemen to bigger things right
so hey we can patch up the line even
more and then make sure what it's good
enough to get a quarterback and trade up
and get a guy if they do it next year
and they take a guy I'm assuming the kid
out of Oregon is the big is a big took a
guy that everybody's looking at but
there are a few guys out there that that
I think but unless you guys are like
lighten it up you know a couple younger
guys are lightening up you know you know
I want to download battles Honda - it
looks incredible but he won't be coming
out this year so it's gonna be one of
those things you got to see if they're
guys out there this should have had four
or five guys even was beta that people
thought really to do it but make sure I
don't know did you know what Odell
Beckham jr. was going in early and a
half time for ya think it's an IV he
probably talked to half so we jogged
into the jog with little to the locker
room I got on the table to get an IV and
then you know there was two seconds left
on the clock
Metis making a big deal out of this
Howard wine because he's over there
Beckham like six one Barclays you know
breaks or breaks a tackle and sixty
yards down so everybody screaming
yelling scores a touchdown
he's high-fiving everybody pumping up
the beach and score know even even give
itto do this bump him on the store we
still in this hotel head butts the fan
and he's on national TV
it's just one of those things it's he's
oh he's a star
you know polarizing guy people like like
watching him yeah I thought it was
unfair the headline that you know he was
going in for an IV and the coach said to
go in for an IV and the training staff
said to go in for an IV then you know I
don't know why that being singled out
here there's there's other head low I
know people click on something like that
but if that's the case I think he's
being unfairly singled out because
the Giants lost last night yeah but he
you know it's a it's a chain reaction
you have an interview and the interview
you say the team needs to do XYZ and now
all of a sudden all the media wants to
know as a team upset that he said these
things and the coach is no finito
everybody's like you know win get on to
that he goes out until the game he
causes a fumble in the end zone on a
punt return so like ah so you're saying
you should spared the team should play
better should have more energy so it's
like to change the action anything we
say is you know we have to be tough you
know you want to get Thomas on we want
content we're holding Mike we want
content so if you say something if you
do something that's content if you don't
say anything there's a god well my
ferret's not speaking to the media but
if he speaks or says anything it's
content so he's gonna be singled out for
the rest of his career he's almost
bigger than the game itself because it's
O'Dell
I don't know why that is but people love
him love to talk about him every every
speech ever give is the questions if you
give question that's the first thing to
face his hotel really that bad of a guy
I'm like the guy that flies around to
children's hospitals and Sue's kids on
his own diner to us not that he's pretty
good but I didn't know that could he be
the could he accept the role of second
best player on the team behind sake on
Berkeley yeah they just want to win when
you're when you're playing that poorly
they just won't win right they're
desperate for a win like it it gets
really heavy on teams when things are
happening and that way you just you'll
do anything for a win you don't really
care who's a star who's not to start
Oldale is gonna get hit and he's gonna
get you know he'll have the hundred plus
yard Knights receiving and then he'll
have nice or not much overwhelm toes the
quarter that could be getting up off the
ground step and so far off the run every
play Howard good to check in with you I
know you got a long season but should be
interesting and we appreciate your time
hey thanks a lot man good talk to you
that's Howard Cross former Giants tight
in he works sidelines for the Giants
broadcast there for more Dan Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]